as soon as we learned of the new omicron
variant this government acted
introducing targeted and proportionate
measures as a precaution whilst our
scientists discovered more and were
learning more every day
we don't yet know omicron's severity its
exact rate of
transmission nor indeed the full
effectiveness of our vaccines against it
but since i last spoke to you it's
become increasingly clear that omicron
is growing much faster than the previous
delta variant and it's spreading rapidly
all around the world
568 cases have been confirmed through
genomic sequencing across every region
of the uk
and the true number is certain to be
much higher
most worryingly there is evidence that
the doubling time of omicron in the uk
could currently be between two and three
days
and while there are some limits on what
we can learn from south africa
because of the different
rates of vaccination different rates of
previous infection we're seeing growth
in cases here
in the uk that now mirrors the rapid
increases previously seen in south
africa
and south africa is also seeing
hospitalizations roughly doubling in a
week
meaning that we can't yet assume that
omicron is less severe than previous
variants
so while the picture may get better and
i sincerely hope that it will we know
that the remorseless logic of
exponential growth could lead to a big
rise in hospitalizations therefore sadly
in deaths
and that's why
it's now the proportionate and the
responsible thing to move to plan b in
england while continuing to work closely
with our colleagues in the devolved
administrations so we slow the spread of
the virus
buy ourselves the time
to get yet more boosters into arms and
especially in the older and more
vulnerable people
and understand the answers to the key
outstanding questions about omicron so
first
we will reintroduce the guidance
to work from home
guidance to work from home employers
should use the rest of the week to
discuss working arrangements with their
employees but from monday you should
work from home if you can
go to work if you must but work from
home if you can all right i know this
will be hard
for uh for many people but by reducing
your contacts in the workplace you will
help slow transmission
second from this friday we will further
extend the legal requirement to wear a
face mask to most to most public indoor
venues including theaters and cinemas
there will be of course exceptions where
it's not practical such as when eating
drinking exercising or singing
third we'll also make the nhs covered
pass mandatory for entry into nightclubs
and venues where large crowds gather
including
unseated indoor venues with more than
500 people
unseated outdoor venues with more than
four thousand people
and any venue with more than ten
thousand people
the nhs
covered pass can still be obtained with
two doses but we will keep this under
review as the boosters roll out
and having taken clinical advice since
the emergence of omicron a negative
lateral flow test will also be
sufficient
as we set out
in plan b
we will give businesses a week's notice
so this will come into force in a week's
time
helping to keep these events and venues
open at full capacity while giving
everyone who attends them confidence
that those around them have done the
responsible thing to minimize risk to
others
as omicron spreads in the community we
will also introduce daily tests for
contacts instead of isolation
so we keep people safe while minimizing
the disruption to daily life
and of course we will take every step to
ensure our nhs is ready for the
challenges ahead
but the single biggest thing that every
one of us can do is to get our jabs and
crucially to get that booster as soon as
our turn
arrives
one year to the day since the uk became
the first country in the world to
administer a coveted vaccine into the
arms of margaret keenan we've opened up
the vaccine booster to all those over 40
and we're reducing the gap between
second dose and booster to a minimum of
just three months
our heroic nhs staff and volunteers have
already done almost 21 million boosters
including reaching 84 of all the
eligible over 80s
but we need to go further and faster
still
because our scientists are absolutely
confident that your immune your immune
response will be stronger if you've been
boosted and while you're at it please
get your flu jab too
let's do everything we can to protect
ourselves and our loved ones this winter
and to reduce the pressures on our nhs
as we learn more so we will be guided
by the hard medical data around four key
criteria
the efficacy of our vaccines and our
boosters the severity of omicron
the speed of its spread and the rate of
hospitalizations
we will constantly
monitor
the data and keep it under review
and of course we must be humble in the
face of this virus
but if and indeed as soon as it becomes
clear that the boosters are capable
of holding
this omicron variant
and we've boosted enough people to do
that job of keeping omicron in
equilibrium then we will be able to move
forward as before so please everybody
play your part and get boosted